okay so first of all uh
the headlock works
on the concept that if i control his
head
i control him okay so i can stabilize
his
head and wherever he moves he tries to
move i can just
check that out
don't make a big goofy thing
here
support your wrist here
if you if you go to punch you can grab
on your leg
down here and you punch here
or you're closing if it supports it
or if you're not punching support the
wrist
lower your center of gravity
so some of you are like this
some of you have terrible stance
so no center of gravity
tight on your body
there you go okay so there's uh
there's a mechanical element so he's
gonna do it go slow
he's gonna do it and see this energy
whoa that's the energetic
so i don't want to go here and yield
i'm sorry resist don't want to resist
go i'm trying to slow it down that's not
what i want
i want to go off balance so he goes
and i just go with it he takes me
second mechanical component he has to be
connected to me any space that's
between us is going to create energy
leakage
and i won't be able to do what i need to
do
so i have to hold and tight
and thirdly my center has to be locked
itself so i can't be having a segmented
frame
so i can't be going like this
my body has to be engaged is in every
aikido technique
then there's a tactical component but if
you're doing the second
mechanical component you'll reach the
tactical component
and that is that i hold this hand
this way this is the danger hand so i
hold it here at the wrist
and here at the arm and i bring it into
me
and that'll take away his space for
punching
and also connect me connect him to me
in the second mechanical component
so i just put it together he goes
over we go
once we go over i keep my center very
low
very much on my side of the point of no
return
with bracing supports on the other side
of that point of no return so he goes
i'm very
loose my center's low on the other side
of his body not high over here
and bracing bracing
i don't want him to keep the residual
energy going
and i go over again
he goes
here okay
i'm going to use my hand
so i have to replace that base of
support so i'm going to put my
foot in replace meant where it is so
whatever his legs are doing
i move him out of the way if his legs
are up
both up please both knees up he's trying
to stop me from coming in
i'll push him down whatever
clear the legs over i go
keeping my center low on the other side
of his body
get my leg in if i'm flexible enough
i'll do it with my own body
if not pull it in and get it near his
body
so he doesn't slip back in and i'm in
the half guard
so i'm landing here check
check near tight on his body
now that's stopping him from rolling me
that way
now i can use this hand on the jaw hinge
at the forearm bone if my arms are long
enough i can stay
outside or if he has
no space i'll go outside
if there's space or my arms are too
short stay inside
push in and bring your head around to
your left
and back outer will go his arm is
trapped now
pull your arm out you can't pull it out
okay replace the trap
pin the head and i'm going to show you
another way of doing it so
you all know the basic way where you
step over
and you have it
if you if you still need to practice
that practice that
if not come here put your knee right on
that same jaw hinge and your windshield
wife
right over
so you're here look
boom center grab be low on the other
side
check clear over pull in if you need to
boom tight jaw hinge
jaw hinge and your windshield wiper
clear and keep check
boom check
this time move up to the jaw hinge
so you clear that carotid
i'm gonna miss it there it is okay
and then grab his hair and bring it up
into it
everything is the same
here i will really open that up
put my knee right in there grab
and pull open
okay
everything's the same i stayed very
tight but look how i'm
bringing him i'm rolling him over
okay i'm rolling him over
rolling him over and i want that arm
trap there
okay so i'm going to roll him over
into the seam that i do my normal
uh arm bar in
it's just so normally this leg would be
under his head
but this time i'm using the top of that
arm
here's one
tight and looking to roll him
his body this leg just i just take it
into that seam
of my body here
okay
[Music]
go slow and incrementally
you're gonna encounter my town okay
and okay everything is the same
get the same frame
create space okay space
then frame
and bring this up onto his shoulder
bottom leg on top and stay up on his
shoulder
and then extend your legs
and when you're trying to go slow
smooth and relax that's the main thing
lose all your attention your intimacy
issues
if someone close to you this this
is your field this is your area this
combat arena to practice relax
he goes i'm very relaxed
don't let your center die so you don't
start segmenting
and you can stick to him he goes
relax
foreign
you learn everything static but static
you're going to find when you go into a
live training environment
it doesn't work and it's not the
techniques
problem it's the trainers the trainees
problem
is it's the problem of form so no one
told you that's the beginning or the
middle or the end but
you as a dichotomous thinking being
you go ahead and create a time sequence
you have a beginning middle end
and then what you'll find is nobody
starts when you say
go in in a fight they're either already
going or they're not going
okay so if you're down
and uh so we're here i'm gonna do the
headlock
get off your back get off your back okay
i'm gonna do the headlock and you're
gonna do the technique and i'm just here
and everything
works
as long as i stay there okay
so as he goes so look at the space he
creates go you see that space come back
so if he goes and he creates a space
we're just right back where we started
and every time he moves i move
and he will never get that technique
so the reason we're doing it
in this kind of sequence is
you can start a micro drill that's what
that technique is
but it's missing its key component
you have to find an environment where in
the middle of their attack
there's room for you to create that
space
and the space gets created because they
were in the middle of their attack
they're not in the middle of defending
me against that move
you get it so as we go we do the
maneuver
as we go upside down i don't have
upside down i don't have upside right i
don't have
right left in out you're gonna find that
i start
once i realize i lost the first
centimeter
waza i'm going to start finding my frame
well before you get that second headlock
i want my elbows in i don't want to
mount i don't want to get in kissing
i'm going to bring my arms in
find the frame and i use your momentum
i'm going to now transfer it into my
moving up the circle and then you go
into that
hole okay so you go i'm very
loose
you see as opposed to
i go
it's not gonna work
if you relax you're just doing the same
aikido energetic transference
but you have to maintain consciousness
through places where most people go
unconscious
they go unconscious inside the hole the
hold inside the attack
inside the roll upside down on the
ground
maintain consciousness and so it just
seamlessly goes into
now they get moved